Це найпопулярніший амстердамський сир Гауда
що визріває 10 місяців
Делікатес можна придбати
також як подарунковий пакунок
з мотивом відомого нідерландського митця
Куірійн Колфф відкрив вже
свою п’яту сирну крамницю
в центрі Амстердама торік у жовтні
Майже одночасно з'явилася
заборона щодо відкриття
нових туристичних магазинів у центрі міста
Я не думаю, що можна вирішити щось
закриваючи сирні крамниці
Гадаю, що варто зробити
і це дуже серйозна дискусія
то це розглядати це з точки зору попиту
як ми збираємося вирішити проблему
що так багато людей приїжджають до цих європейських міст
Чому можливо, що стільки літаків прибувають сюди
і що так багато бронювань можна робити в готелях
Рішення мусять ухвалюватися на цьому рівні
Майже сімнадцять мільйонів туристів
приїжджають щороку до Амстердама
Вони хочуть побачити передусім
центр міста з його багатьма каналами
Місто вже зробило кілька спроб
зупинити хвилю туристів
Приміром, не можна здавати в оренду квартиру
якщо вона не зареєстрована офіційно
як житло для туристів
Заборонено відкривати нові готелі в центрі міста
Також мерія припинила будь-які
рекламні кампанії Амстердама
Рік тому ми ухвалили нову політику
щодо регулювання туризму
Вона передбачає зменшення чи обмеження кількості магазинів
які працюють виключно для туристів
Тобто жодних нових туристичних крамниць
І сирні крамниці також входять у цей перелік
Так само багато інших сувенірних крамниць
і закладів фаст-фуд
як, приміром, відома мережа Ice Bakers
підпадають під "санкції" амстердамської мерії
Місцеві мешканці вітають таку
ініціативу міської влади
називаючи її "операцією нутелла"
Я вважаю, це чудово
Тому що ці магазини з "нутеллою" руйнують все
їх тут стільки розплодилося!
І це одна з причин, чому більше немає
нормальних магазинів
Наприклад, одягу чи просто хліба
Це на краще
Тому що ці крамниці просто жахливі
Я живу тут вже 44 роки
Перші двадцять були спокійними
але останні 10 тут просто неймовірно велелюдно
Що буде з новою крамницею амстердамського сиру
поки не зрозуміло
За словами власників, остаточне рішення
ще не ухвалено
Доки цього не сталося, магазин працюватиме
У разі чого власник готовий позиватися проти мерії